good morning john
around 10 years ago i was scheduled to
make a video on december 14 2012. i had
a whole idea for it and then the sandy
hook attack happened and i
did not know what to do so i made a
short video trying to be honest about
where i was in that moment and i just
went back and watched that video and my
takeaway from that is that in that
moment the unique tragedy of sandy hook
felt very unique there had been other
mass shootings and school shootings that
created terror and horror and tragedy
but like a young adult walking into an
elementary school with an ar-15 i could
not imagine that and this time
we had all imagined it we'd spent 10
years imagine it we've spent 10 years
preparing children for it i got a letter
from our school yesterday talking about
the precautions they take and like no
like there aren't any precautions we
can't put the responsibility on schools
to handle men with weapons of war
we cannot educate our children in bank
vaults we can't put razor wire around
the playground
it feels like this country is being
constantly re-traumatized
and that is made worse when we ask our
leaders to try out some solutions and we
hear some of them respond
now is not the time for politics
and this phrase can be heard in two very
different ways because one definition of
politics is the stuff we do to govern
and by that measure
this is certainly the time for politics
because political leaders are elected to
implement policy and a majority of
americans want meaningful policy changes
when it comes to gun safety but of
course there's also another meaning to
the word politics it's the game it's the
jockeying for favorability politics as
theater manipulating the electorate and
doing all your fundraising and i agree
with that this is not the time for
theater it's the time for the other kind
of politics the actual doing things kind
but instead when they say this is not
the time for politics what they're doing
is the second kind of politics they're
waiting until we get over it until the
news cycle gets done with it and
simultaneously they're saying americans
who have concerns about gun safety
they're not worried about kids they're
just playing politics
and that is disgusting
the fear of having your child not come
home from school one day is just about
the biggest possible fear and so it
seems like people who oppose gun safety
legislation or want to use it as a wedge
issue have had to match that with a
similarly big fear but what fear could
be that big how could the fear of taking
away not even your current assault rifle
but your right to buy one in the future
in any way match the fear of having your
child taken away
well what about the fear of having
everything taken away
so that's what many of them resort to
their argument is often literally that
americans need guns to fight against
their government people who want gun
safety legislation want their leaders to
take this problem seriously and it's not
like it isn't a problem because guns are
now the number one killer of people
under the age of 19.
but after sandy hook when bans on
assault rifles or universal background
checks were proposed the counter to the
fear of losing your child in a school
shooting was the fear that your
government is a menace that cannot be
trusted and so you must be armed to
protect yourself against them this is a
fringe belief that has been promoted by
politicians and pundits in order to
create a wedge that can help them win
elections
sandy hook has a lot of legacies but the
politicians and pundits who took the
absolutely legitimate interest americans
had in gun safety legislation and used
it as a wedge not just to fight that
legislation but to delegitimize the
government that they are sworn to uphold
that is the very worst of the second
kind of politics and every time they say
this is not the time for politics that's
the kind of politics i hear your job is
to take this country's problems
seriously not to drum up fear to
manipulate others into hating and being
terrified of their fellow citizens and
their government so that you can win a
primary
john i'll see you on tuesday